[Applause]
hi everyone uh my name is Brennan brck
um and I'm a senior data science analyst
um a Mayo Clinic in the Robert D
Patricia e krent center for the science
of healthcare delivery I know try to fit
that on a
sweater uh so in the in the current
Center in the data science pillar
specifically uh um our main goal is to
support male clinics medical practice
through the of statistical and machine
learning models that are well backed by
Healthcare delivery models um and what
uh a healthcare delivery model to me is
essentially uh the information that your
model is providing should be in use and
it should change practice in some way um
it should be integrated into other
others workflows not just your
own um so we have a mantra within our
group that a model with good predictions
is useless unless there is a
well-developed healthcare delivery model
behind it or as even stated by David
Robinson at this very conference in 2019
anything still just on your computer by
any first approximation is useless um
good models should be well utilized by
people that can use the information that
they're providing to affect change um
and to us that means that our models
need to be in production so we need to
develop models in a principled way uh we
also need to develop data prediction
pipelines princi bed and finally we need
to deliver those predictions to someone
who can actually do something about
that um there's one thing that I kind of
want you to take away from this talk is
that none of this that I'm talking about
I I feel is overly complicated um you
don't have to be a devops or a software
engineer to put model your models into
production um I am neither of these
things um you don't need you also don't
need a team of analysts to accomplish
this goal either um you just need to
utilize the right tools and workflows to
help you
out um so where we're going or where
where I hope to take you is uh
throughout the entire process but where
we're working towards is supporting
clinical applications such as this one
um that I've worked on uh in shiny that
uh where we're displaying uh real
predictions real time on on patients in
mayo clinics
hospital um so through uh throughout the
course of this talk I'll I'm going to
introduce a a real project that I work
on the respiratory car n project and I'm
going to hopefully take you through the
um the modeling portion of this project
all the way to taking it uh into
production utilizing targets um that we
just learned a lot about um we'll talk
about how to make these pipelines these
Target pipelines more reproducible more
portable uh utilizing tools like uh rnv
and uh and git and then finally I'll
talk about accessibility and enablement
using the POS connect server uh shiny
and plumber okay so the respiratory
carry in a project is a uh project that
we currently have working in production
um that essentially tries to solve uh
this uh um this problem so Mayo Clinic
has a um a hospital it has an intensive
care unit um and the typical uh typical
pathway for a patient is that they uh
are stabilize in the ICU they then move
to a general care floor um as a step
down unit and hope uh and discharge from
there um clinicians noticed though
however that there is the subset of
patients that had respiratory issues
that would be stabilize in the ICU they
would go to the general care floor but
their conditions would be exacerbated um
which would require either a readmit to
the ICU which is bad um or they end up
in a a Respiratory Care Unit more
specialized Respiratory Care Unit and
probably all along they should have gone
to that Respiratory Care Unit um when
they discharge from the
ICU so the problem um that we are trying
to model is essentially we want to
classify who is likely to end up in the
RCU after they discharge from the
ICU um so with a lot of healthc care uh
uh projects you kind of can sketch out
four sort of General steps that we need
to accomplish in order to develop such a
model we need to define a cord of
patients um that being the like a a
historical set of ICU patients um that
we observe throughout their encounter um
we then need to pull their covariate
data from the EHR the electronic health
record on a number of uh topics that
might be predictive like lab notes
demographics medications etc etc then
finally we need to combine all that
together and train and validate a model
and if we're successful
successful uh we get to put that model
into production or we uh to start
utilizing it and you can take those uh
those four General steps and you can
start sketching out what you need to
write in terms terms of our scripts so
you might you might start with a 01
cohort script that pulls uh historical
data uh then you also have a number of
uh scripts to pull that pull and clean
EHR data and then um some um um some
scripts to pull that together and train
a
model um this workflow requires a kind
of eighth metascript where you Source
each one of those uh scripts that you
defined previously um in or uh you
basically run them um
sequentially um but if we were to draw
the dependency graph for this project
you might realize that parts of this
might be uh inefficient um you you'll
notice that uh demo labs and notes
they're kind of all independent we can
kind of pull uh and process those
independent um and so kind of where this
manifests itself is um say we have to we
want to add a new lab feature to our
data set a clinician that we're working
with says hey uh you should really
consider this lab it's it might be
indicative of an underlying respiratory
issues um so we do that we add it um we
add it to our lab script um but really
the only things that we should have to
rerun are um that lab's uh data file uh
pulling together like your your whole
data set and training a model but in
that Source scripting way of doing
things you're rerunning
everything um everything again no matter
what you change uh in your
pipeline um so it's that's
inefficient um on top of that uh you're
all the inputs and outputs of all these
various scripts need to be managed by
you and not only do they need to be
managed by you but they're also hidden
away in this sort of workflow you like
uh we can't tell uh apparently what what
cohort passes on to Labs what labs
passes on to uh you know uh your model
framing etc
etc and when we when it when it comes
down to real projects such as the RCU
project this is the real graph that uh
the RCU project produced um if you had
to rerun all these nodes yourself every
single time and you had if or if you had
to keep track of all these inputs and
outputs yourselves it really becomes
unruly uh and really air prone and when
we're talking about um
delivering uh the point of this pipeline
is to uh hopefully de deliver better
patient outcomes um and when we need to
when we're talking about real patient
outcomes we need to be correct we can't
we can't uh do things in in such a air
prone uh in such an air prone
Manner and so that's where the targets
package really comes and helps out in
all of our our process processes we're
targets allows us to iterate through
multiple various uh ideas uh very
quickly um when working on such projects
so targets is a pipeline Automation and
management tool that tracks that
essentially does all the stuff that I
said is bad about that Source scripting
workflow it handles that all for
you um very simple to uh Define a
targets workflow you simply need a
Target script that defines a targets
list whose elements are the nodes in the
graph um that I that I showed earlier
and each element uh is a target that has
this named uh function pair where um you
need a a name for the the data object
you're creating as well as a reusable
function that defines that object so on
on very simplistically on the right hand
side um you can kind of re uh read what
a target's workflow is doing by cohort
gets uh Define cohort demo gets get
demographics etc
etc and all you need to do to facilitate
or run the pipeline is to run a simple
function called tarake and targets uh
builds all of those objects for
you and I skipped ahead quite a
bit um everyone close their
eyes and so in uh in that
uh that example where I changed uh uh
the the lab feature data set um so if I
did that with targets
um uh targets knows what needs to be
rerun in my Pipeline and it's going to
skip un unnecessary uh rerunning of a
certain objects so in the case of labs
it re rebuilds Labs but it skips over um
stuff that wasn't actually dependent on
that
object and the very nice thing about uh
defining workflows in this way is that
so since targets requires you to Define
reusable functions and targets also is
going to require you or encourages you
to stick all your functions into a
directory named arm and if you humor me
and like kind of squint your eyes with
those two um requirements you kind of
you might be able to see the makings of
what is in a package or what you need to
do to define a package and the very nice
consequence of this is that you get to
reuse all the code that you wrote during
the modeling part of your project and
apply it directly into when you need to
make prospective predictions in
production so in the in the modeling uh
sort modeling sense you uh you're
pulling data on a retrospective set of
data uh pulling all the coari
information that you need uh to Define
uh um uh to make predictions and then
you uh you fit a model then in the
production pipeline you simply need to
load that model you created into the
kind of first modeling
pipeline start pulling uh patients that
are in the ICU
currently um and then you get all all of
that work for free all all that uh all
the way that you pulled and cleaned um
your information is consistent uh to
make your predictions so the benefits of
this is that you spend a lot less time
putting your models into prod because
you're reusing all that code that you
that you developed that code base uh is
very
reusable as well there's this nice
benefit that it assures that your
prospective data um the data that you're
pulling uh kind of currently in
production is cleaned in the same way as
your retrospective data
um uh because the the the the rules that
you define to clean and pull data is
every bit as important to the modeling
workflow as kind of the algorithm that
you're using to uh to using to fit a
model at the end of the day to make
valid predictions
prospectively um so now that I talked
about making uh like all the pipelining
that we need let's talk about making
those pipelines more St stable more
ready for production
use um we kind of have an opinionated
like kind uh kind of like a g flow um of
certain like branching logic and and
stuff like that and like certain
requirements for uh each one of a a
project that we're working on in the
current Center um and I'm uh I'm going
to distribute the slides earlier uh and
I'm not going to cover all these points
um but to kind of summarize uh the
workflow this opinionated workflow that
we've come up with um it's to use
targets for each project to use targets
to use renv and to use git um for all
all
projects um I've covered targets but I
kind of want to just point out it has
this very Le interface um to recreate it
uh using
tarake uh
RN uh helps us sell this problem of each
project gets its own set of isolated
packages um that that you get to manage
on the project level
um so you you can you're you're
confident that every time you rerun this
pipeline uh you know the set of packages
that um go into it and the problem that
this solves is having like uh having a
package updated um kind of under your
nose and uh uh maybe maybe everyone else
realizes that this is kind of not like a
smart way to do this but we used to
share packages across multiple uh across
multiple projects um when we were doing
uh kind of research only
workflows um and so this was a real
thing that happened deer would get uh
updated under your nose and you'd kind
of like be struggling to figure out
exactly what changed um in your code and
and and it wouldn't have been you and
then finally we like to uh each project
should be in a code repository um and
you should commit all the all the
necessary files to capture the state of
your project at any time um and uh get
usually comes with uh like code
repositories like Ado or GitHub um so
you can use those tools to manage code
changes and deployments of those code
changes uh in
production and kind of just to uh what
git is sort of helping us with is is
saving us from um saving multiple
versions of a of a final
model um very nice consequence of all
using all these tools together is
Extreme
portability um so I might not be running
this project uh where I'm currently
running it today but I know I can be
confident that if I have to change where
the compute happens if I need more
compute power Etc that I can very easily
move these projects uh and maintain my
reproducibility um where essentially all
I need to do is is clone a get
repository want run a ren restore to get
all the packages I need and then finally
run tarake to restore my pip uh all the
objects that I
created um and so finally I want to talk
about uh project enablement so we've
covered
um developing pipelines making them more
stable and PR ready but final uh back to
that M that point that I made earlier is
that well isn't it you it's useless
right if it's just sitting on my
computer running predictions um and so
so how we um how we enable our work is
we rely a lot on the posit connect
server and what the posit connect server
does for us is it allows us to make uh
web applications to display our
predictions in real time for
clinicians um the shiny shiny helps us
accomplish that very easy we're able to
prototype um sort of dashboards really
quickly and as well we can write plumber
apis to allow others to work um with uh
uh other software to work with our
work and kind of how I like to uh
um illustrate the the the how connect is
actually very powerful for for us is to
enable or to show what this workflow
might have been like five years ago when
I didn't have connect and that probably
meant that I was emailing these
predictions to a clinician who is
working in the hospital super smart
right and I would probably have to do
that as much as they would stomach it
and probably eventually they would
ignore it um I also have to assume that
nothing is going to change in the time
that they actually VI view the my file
and when that patient actually
discharges so a world with connect uh
we're able to display um all that
information that we're trying to convey
to a clinician um real time in a in a
web application um we're also able to uh
store their decisions that they're
making so that we can evaluate uh a
model's performance over time
uh and this is this is great um it
allows us to really find out if there's
efficacy to the models that we're
putting uh into production are we
actually affecting uh patient
outcomes um so there might be a scenario
where your model is so um so good uh
that the clinicians want it to be become
a part of a patient's medical history um
they want your model result to be in in
the medical record essentially so the
problem that we need to solve uh I guess
here is that we need to put R in the
medical record um and while fiveyear old
five years ago me might have been naive
enough to go to the people at Epic go to
the people who run the EHR and be like
well it's our is open source uh I'll
find you the link to download it you can
put on your servers no problem right uh
that's just not how things work and the
way uh a very elegant way that we get to
solve this problem is the use of plumber
API so kind of going back to that uh
notion of reusable functions we get to
Define uh functions in r that uh other
groups um that are trying to utilize the
uh our models um the uh they get to
interact with um all that uh Machinery
all those pipelines that we created for
a project um they get to interact with
it very
easily um and so that's all I have uh
thank you thank you
everybody thank you so much Brendan
great job um so we do have some
questions and thank you everyone for for
actually submitting questions um in
advance this is great so um one question
here is how do you avoid feedback loops
where your predictions of who will be
readmitted contributes to that occurring
and bias future uh model R
trinings uh sorry can you repeat that
yeah so um how do you avoid the feedback
loops where your predictions of who will
be readmitted right uh to the ICU
contributes to that occurring and biases
Future model retraining so the same data
biasing the future retraining sure so I
think uh uh with any with any modeling
framework uh or with any any model there
there are some assumptions that you you
need to uh live with
um so I would say to avoid avoid
feedback uh it's it's it's a Val concern
and it is something that we that we
looked into um but really um we're we're
not really adjusting or modifying what
we're doing for for that Fe those those
um those readmits yeah makes sense um
another question here is how might you
change this workflow if you were to pull
live data for example like
vitals like if this was actual live data
oh if it was actual live data um so I
think the best way to do that is just
start but um and I I I I understand it
like is hard but it's to kind of go to
the source that you're going to be
pulling in a live scenario if you can do
that upfront in those reusable in like
in in your function calls so that when
you go to productionize it um you're
you're utilizing that those same
resources kind of how um we've combed
that is so we have MSS uh SQL Server
that we kind of um
combined together um from the start of
when we're modeling it so um pulling
historic data um and then combining that
with uh real time uh we use it's called
fire uh fire apis to get real-time data
we kind of try to do that from the start
of a of a project so that we' know so it
is more seamless to go from um modeling
to production well thank you again
Brandon appreciate it
[Applause]
y